think about it in your 20s if you want
to get your career lined up because
let's be real a two-income household
goes a lot further sometimes than a one
angle one income household
get you can get your career done by 24.
and i'm not kidding you can be 16 to 18
you get yourself in um like a dual
enrollment program in high school so you
graduate with your associate's degree or
maybe you decide to serve in the
military four years done you got a gi
bill and you get into a stem degree you
just you can have your career set up
halfway if not fully by age 24 and then
you can go out there and pick any duty
that you want because i get women want
to know if we can actually make things
happen for ourselves and you can most
definitely accomplish nursing school by
the age of 24 you can accomplish being
possibly i think if you're really a hard
charger being a physician's assistant by
the age 24. so you get your career out
of the way your apartment's nice your
bills are paid and guess what you got
access to some higher quality men
because people ask me how do you meet
high-value myths work for them
be a dental hygienist